we are here inside the sports book so we
want to show you all about it okay
we have a limited vantage point here but
let me bring your attention to the
fantastic screens
thanks to our fabulous photographer this
is the world's
largest sports book three stories tall
this screen contains 78 million pixels
now it takes 10 people to operate
up to 1 000 people can be seated here
and of course we got a number of
different types of areas that offer a
little something for everyone
depending on your price point let's
break that down for you starting with
the super special area called the dugout
that's that first area there with the
brown chairs
it's got vip cushion chairs directly in
front
we've got the legends club that's got
the plush recliners just behind the
dugout
and the champions club section is
perfect for those larger groups
it's got the long booth style seating
and then you've got the circle club
upper and circle club lower sections the
north and south stands
we've got the seats that are equipped
with the power outlets and of course
food and beverage service
there's also the vision studio which
gives bettors real-time in-depth
analysis from the broadcasters the
athletes and the industry professionals
50 hours of live programming each and
every week it's really a better paradise